Friday at that food truck diary with the
style bender mmm late though man we did
it like 4:30 he's a he's a veteran kid
fan yeah yeah was that what was that
like he's such an interesting dude yeah
he's great he's he's big man
he's [ __ ] yeah I was like he's as
tall as you are well the yeah yeah he
might be told me my niche we might be
the same height but he's six four
yeah yeah but when the rumors about him
and John Jones came about fighting I was
like you're out your goddamn mind
yeah like he's too small for John John
you get wrestled to the no team person
like oh oh no you could do it he goes
why do you think yeah my team months we
want to fight him so he wants to fight
John Jones oh yeah
I don't know he that's the plan he said
2021 they're gonna fight in Vegas so so
what are you that's a very intriguing
idea I feel like John Jones is just too
much too big for him I didn't say me but
when you see me in person yeah I can do
time cover now he's 208 like you yeah
Jesus Christ
yeah you forget yeah he's about it he's
6 for big and I was like you big dude
he and his his hands are huge Wow but
just a really really good dude smart
smartly head man they [ __ ] my Geryon
but Australian is he does they identify
more with being Nigerian or are
Australia he moved to Auckland New
Zealand for a better at his family
wanted to have a better education is
very Nigerian though he strikes me his
way Mormon this is what's interesting
here is he just bought this car he
bought this in fear car guy it's like a
big boy car it's a it's a 720's McLaren
it's one of the fastest cars in the
world why is he's paying his money on
his gun on that right now I guess he's a
champion so [ __ ] it maybe they gave it
to him uh no he bought it but he's I
don't want Tabas financial business but
he's very smart he's Nigerian okay
you're Nigerian if you're the only money
here's the other thing got well not all
no I mean no but they say no well no no
what I mean is by Nigerian in Nigeria
like he comes from a large family
and I can
guarantee that they are generally pretty
good with as a group participants yeah
but the other thing is is
yeah I didn't know he's a car guy but
buying a 720s McLaren is pretty
inspecting is but here's the thing he's
not a huge car guy
he showed me one of the reasons he got
it cuz he's really into anime and he was
look at the AI character and it's or
it's like this wolf thing I don't know
anime he's gonna kick it's like this I
am a snarl Japanese or nine tails yeah
Japanese like a wolf that's orange and
black and the I was similar to the
McLaren 720's car
she does look at it do you know it oh
you're not a car guy but the car you
borrow here an anime car you bots I mean
it's like going from from a Casio to uh
it's like going from a dollar to a tiger
as a pet I mean it's crazy what what is
that what is that what's that run me if
I want to if I want to dip my toe into
the car world and I want I want to go
right to the top
he's about that because you know there's
not a ton of those in New Zealand so
there's the mark up in New Zealand's
pretty crazy too I would assume he paid
around 400 at okay the cool thing about
these cars that you're buying is that
you get your money back kind of though
right you're kind of driving a family
the McLaren not not as much so as the
Porsche that I bought okay but he's
gonna sign it for this isn't a bad Buy I
was so proud of style bender I was so
proud of Israel when he told me he kept
out of 720's I'm like you son of a [ __ ]
I'm intrigued by this [ __ ] John Jones
[ __ ] I am too because when news broke I
was like I even told chin when he
brought up on below the bed I was like
I'm not gonna entertain this dude this
never happened John Jones is too big you
know just was like it's so silly it's
it's good for them to talk about and
then right when Israel walked in I'm
like holy [ __ ] dude you're big guy I was
like I sound like Bryan Callen right now
yeah I went you're a big guy guess
people see me like oh he really is big
yeah and like now the Jon Jones thing
that seems so crazy seeing that we're
like oh [ __ ] he's Syria and he's that
[ __ ] confident yeah he has this
similar trait that we've only really
seen with with Conor McGregor where they
say stuff and it actually happens you
know where they say stuff and yeah where
a lot of fighters say stuff and doesn't
seem very organic or natural when he
speaks it kind of comes to fruition and
skilled he has a whole whole plan you
know you gotta remember - he's 39 he's
been fighting for it I'm not really
footing but not even that the point is
is it's not like you know he's this
young kid who bought a McLaren here's
all the success he got the UFC at the
perfect time hmm and he had a lot of
fights before that a lot of fights
before that and also you know he's only
been in the OC for two years mmm two
years world champion he's got a fight
uol
know I knew what everyone's yeah you
always coming off the loss that's right
Paul Acosta was supposed to be but
Paulo's hurt so all right you know
there's Darin till there's there's
Romero either he's just very smart very
creative individual yeah just that mom
just checks all the boxes man as far as
to be a superstar yeah I told him on
camera that he's the that he's the
biggest star in the UFC I would agree
with that name can you name one bigger
kid John's definitely not no he's the
biggest right now for sure yeah I was
just one of the things that I was amazed
about with that with that Whitaker fight
there was a subtle thing that I saw that
that he was able to cus be right there
and his he's he's he was impossible to
touch as he was in the proximity of
somebody who's limited he's that bigger
still his ability to kind of like move
his face just out of the way those
little details and stay in the pocket
gets the 70 professional kickboxing
fights yeah there you go
so when you're going against these MMA
fighters yeah much more advanced that's
what I mean and it's such a subtle thing
you like you're like you just can't you
can't get a clean shot on its face you
can't really burn all these other guys
it's it's gonna be tough for him to map
that that's why he's gonna be champion
for a long time because he is that
experienced in that background I watched
me and Roberto about the fights this
weekend with Greg Hardy it's just like
he did well but it's like what's his
ceiling well there's gonna become a
certain point where listen he fought
this vet he was never even close to
winning but he did how to get show up
but it's like is he ever gonna be a
top-ten guy no who are you talking to
Greg Hardy
I think am i hating on him no it's just
at his age and the the amount of a
football player yeah the amount of
experience that he lacks is just never
gonna start gonna work for him just not
right now
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]